So it's my great pleasure to,
introduce Eran
Avidan of Intel.
Eran is a machine learning
engineer and architect
of the advanced
analytics group at Intel,
which delivers AI and big data
solutions across Intel.
His work at
the Advanced Analytics
Group includes research and
development of cutting edge
distributed architectures in
the AI domain.
So let's give
a warm warm welcome
to Aram, and, and we
can get started.
Over over to you.
So hi, everyone.
So I was introduced,
very formally,
very excited, to be
here, starting this,
presentation day.
And, today, I want
to share with
you and give you
a bit of a overview
of what we did for our sales
department at Intel.
Actually, a project,
building and
maintaining a knowledge
graph we started
working on two
years ago. And,
to continue my introduction,
my name is Ivan, and,
I'm a machine
learning engineer
and the architect
of, Intel IT AI.
And been working
at the Advanced
Analytics Group
for the past ten
years or so,
where we provide,
products and solution across
many of Intel's division,
specifically machine learning
and artificial intelligence,
solutions from,
helping better
design the chips
through manufacturing,
increasing the yields
through analytics,
up until sales and marketing
where we help
increase the revenues
by recommendation
systems, and so on.
And we even have
some products,
working with Mobileye,
harnessing insights from cars
that transmit data through,
Mobileye sensored vehicles.
But today, we're gonna talk
about sales and marketing,
and I would like to introduce
you to our sales AI system.
But before that,
let's talk a little bit about
our sales department.
Intel sales department,
like every other
big enterprise,
is is huge. It's
actually a division.
It's huge. It's composed of
thousands of people,
account managers
covering hundreds
of thousands of,
customer accounts.
And they can offer,
hundreds of different products
from CPUs, soon to be GPUs,
and memory and storage.
This enormous complexity,
may lead to some
missed business
opportunities. And this is why
we've built, this
sales AI platform.
We're looking to
bridge this gap
of missed opportunities
by first,
in real time, scan
customer information,
store it, detect
intent to buy,
and maybe identify
some potential
opportunities, automating and
recommending
a personal or best
action for
the account manager,
and then feeding
back to the system
learning based on
customer response.
So that's the sales
AI framework
we've been working
on for the past
six years. And over
the past six years,
our sales AI program
led to a community
of sales revenue growth of
approximately more
than half a billion
dollars. And through
those years,
we've supplied
different solutions
for account managers.
And to give you an example,
one such solution is called
the sales assist as it assists
account managers
in identifying
new business opportunities,
with leads about
their respective
customers. For instance,
an account manager
can open his
dashboard and see
the companies that it,
he or she covers and
see that company a,
we're gonna talk a lot a lot
about company a,
is about to attend
the conference.
Or maybe they
browse into website
for products they
never purchased
before, and this may
lead to a business
opportunity. And
we all these,
we supplied many
such solution,
but then we started
thinking, well,
all these insights
that we give
account managers,
are they visible
for any future
model or system that inquires
about company a?
Or do we even have a single
layer of sensing where
we store all the,
information we
collect for future
progress? Do we store back all
the insights into that same
place where someone can query
about company and get
all the information
back? And the answer,
as you can imagine,
was, no. We do not.
So we decided to
start studying now.
We decided to record
all activities
as well as insights
into a single
centralized place.
This would basically simulate
in the sensing part
what an account
manager would do.
So we look at sensing at scale
in a nutshell,
what I'm talking
about to, give
you an example.
It it starts from
basic information
that the company gives us with
enrolls into Intel's program,
like location and
maybe the field
it works in.
Then we can start
recording some
internal information,
sales transactions,
what they bought,
how many, maybe what courses
they took in, for
Intel products.
Up to,
collecting customer website
information and going through
social media and
recording these
activities as well.
So usually, when
you take pieces
of information,
then they're
scattered all over
the place. But we decided to
take all those silos
of information,
all those silos of data,
and and put them into a single
centralized knowledge graph.
And why would one store store
these things in
a graph structure?
So for us,
the motivation was,
I believe, similar
to a lot of others.
The world is
composed of entities
and relationship
between them.
So this makes things very easy
to explain. When you give
predictions or even a simple
analysis of a situation,
you can show a graph
and it makes sense.
When you want
information about
some kind of entity,
for instance,
company a, everything
is really close.
So I want things
about company a.
Like, everything is
one hop, two hop,
or maybe three hops away,
but I get this
nice image about
company a. And
since everything
is really
dynamically structured
and you're not limited
to any schema,
you can simply add
more data easily,
connect it to
company a if it's
relevant to company a.
And when you have,
started growing a nice
knowledge graph,
then you can infer knowledge
directly from that graph,
simply by traversing
it or running
simple, graph algorithms.
And later on, you can use that
graph as it grows and grows.
They have a really
great knowledge
base for AI as we're gonna see
in a few slides.
So we started
thinking we wanna
grow an old graph,
and I'll illustrate
how things work,
when it comes to sales and
marketing at the end.
First off,
company a enrolled into into
this program to
become a distributor
or buy products for itself.
What it was enrolling,
get some basic information.
It says that it's
part of the IoT and,
the NAR industries,
and it's it's
a builder in those
industry. Later on,
we started saving
some internal
information. Through
sales transaction,
company a went on and bought
product six and product y,
and we connected company a to
those products in our
knowledge graph.
And as a side effect,
we got that company
a is interested
in data center products.
Then looking at
company a's website,
we we've noticed
our smart medical
devices. So maybe we can add
this edge of company
a to the health
care industry. Then there was
a social media
tweet that company
b have invested in company a,
so we can connect
company a with
company b. And
if we're lucky,
we may have company b in our
knowledge graph,
and then we get
some secondhand
information about company a.
Company a went on and browsed
intel dot com, and we recorded
that activity. And there was
more and more activities which
we recorded and
added edges for.
And what's interesting is that
we started only with what we
were told about
company a given
by company a.
And this union of internal and
external data
sources can create
a really strong
knowledge base,
which is basically the basic
basis of our knowledge graph.
You can simply take any piece
of information you get about
company a and edit
as you're not
restricted, to any
specific schema.
And this information,
and this is key,
will not be hidden
somewhere in
some other data sources.
You can simply
query about company
a and everything, by
the number of hops,
and you will get
all the information
about company a and
anything related.
You can then if
you wanna train
a model relating
companies, you can say,
I wanna extract
features about,
company a. So maybe I'll I'll
do it by proximity,
and I can rank those features
by any graph logic,
I determine or,
for instance, by the distance
from the company I know.
And then I get
a set of features
to train my AI model.
And if we think about it,
most of these
things are facts.
And using the knowledge graph
algorithms, we
can generate more
and more edges with
some confidence
that as our assumption,
is and was and still that we
live in a world
where we always
have only part
of the knowledge
even if we have all the data.
So in a graph,
this is is very easy to extend
our knowledge by adding more
edges between existing nodes,
between existing data points,
simply generating
more knowledge
with data that we
already have.
And let's move,
to the more technical part or
that the idea or the solution
that we built in order to make
this graph grow.
So identifying information was
basically flowing in
through the system.
We've decided to
build a stream
processing system.
Specifically, we build one
asynchronously to make it also
more efficient.
And we start thinking
what would,
what we would need
for such a system.
And we've identified several
capabilities we believe are
crucial for this process,
and we've designed,
respective component for each
one of them. So if we look at
the architecture
in high level,
and again, this is
an abstraction,
the capabilities are the key
things here.
We see that we have
a microservice
architecture, and
we have a component
for each capability
we're gonna
talk about. And
we have a message
bus since everything
is asynchronous.
We have a message
bus in the middle
which synchronizes things.
And there are
loaders which load
internal data. And since we
because this is the basic
information we
have and we knew
we wanted to load it,
But then we knew we wanted to
transform it
somehow into graph
formation, so created
the transformers,
which is the second
capability.
We want to enrich
this internal
data with external
information.
So we created the extractors,
which go out to the web and
fetch new information about
internal information where all
they have.
Everything needed
to be persisted
into a graph database,
so we created
the graph builder.
And to keep everything
up to date,
specifically external
information,
we created refreshers.
And let's talk a little bit
about each one of
those capabilities
and, what we
believe we need in
order to make this happen.
So the loaders,
they import internal
data as I stated,
and they support a variety of
sources and formats.
It's it's kind of
a plug in system.
It's a microservice based,
architecture, and
they work with
the push or pull.
They can query daily from SQL
database or can
they can get a push
notification from
the size five
system that the CSV
have just arrived.
They load the data.
They convert it
into JSON format
and publish it to the message
bus to later be
transformed and
persistent. So the loaders are
fairly simple. The
second capability,
this is actually the basic
processing unit of the system
are the transformers.
And these do the most,
let's say,
probably are
the most busy logic
wise as they
convert information
into graph semantics,
into graph formations.
They're always on.
They're all they
asynchronous.
They're stateless,
which make them by nature
extremely fault
tolerant and scalable.
We specifically use the Kafka
streams technology,
but you can use
whatever you want.
The transformers know how to
transform information
into graph
formations by
configurations per entity.
This specific
transformer knows
how to transform
product information,
which it gets from
internal data
or external data into
nodes and edges.
And it does so simply
by configuration.
We've created
a nice YAML based
DSL that tells which fields
become which node and which,
field becomes which edge and
which nodes it connects.
And it goes on and on.
And this DSL became more and
more robust up until a system
analyst can simply
configure any new,
source information it found,
it finds in order to instruct
the transformer
how to transform
this information into
nodes and edges.
So that's, let's
say, like the,
middleman, the expert
in the middle.
Since the internal information
is not enough, we we created
the extractors,
which actually trans extends
transformers. They
also transform
the information into
graph formations,
but they also enrich it with
some external information.
So on top of being configured
per entity, per product,
in this case,
they're also configured
per data source.
You would need
to instruct them
how to get this
external information
and what to do with it,
with what kind of
post processing
to do with it when they,
retrieve that information
the information
. For instance,
running matching
algorithms of
sorts and scoring
the validity of
the information
they just got. They
just received,
that is.
The next capability
is the most
b d the like,
the busiest place
in our system is
the graph builder.
It's only sure is to translate
those graph formations into
graph query language.
In our case, we support Cypher
as we work with Neo four j.
It's the most
prevalent, I think,
GQLs out there.
And the graph builder,
you can think about it
like a microservice
data layer.
Nobody writes to the graph
database by but
the graph builder
Since you wanna
keep everything
in check, you don't want any
other processes disturbing,
your throughput
or the integrity
of your knowledge graph.
The Graph Builder,
same as every other
mod microservice,
is very scalable.
So you can scale
it out or in,
depending what throughput you
need and what
resources you have.
And if you're worried about
the graph database we
chose, Neo four j.
So when we started working at
two or three years ago,
we've examined many
graph databases.
We found Neo four
j to be the most
mature and and
fairly stable one.
It's really easy to use.
It supports Cypher,
which actually
decouples us from
Neo four j as we can always
switch to other databases that
support Cypher, that
work with Cypher.
But for me and and a lot of
other people,
the the best selling
point was the great UI.
You you remember
that we talked
I I talked. You
listen about, decks.
The it's easy to explain.
Well, it's easy to explain if
you have a UI. If you
don't have a UI,
it's very hard to explain.
So, this is actually
a screenshot
we're gonna talk a little bit
about later that I took a year
ago from our knowledge graph.
The last component
of refreshers,
they're fairly simple.
They are the only
one that query
the graph as they
simply traverse
the graph looking
for stale nodes.
Once they find
the stale node,
they trigger an extractor.
In this case,
a product extractor,
in order to fetch
and refresh that,
data or that information
in the graph,
and they move on to look for
other failed notes.
And if you wanna
keep your graph
up to date, you
should have a few
running and traversing
the graph.
They're like
agents looking for
old nodes and edges
and updating them,
as time goes by.
So this was the architecture.
But let's talk a little bit
about what we did with and how
about what what the graph
structure actually
looks like.
So the first thing
that we will
approach with, like,
some kind of proof
of concept,
was we the business wanted to
get a view of customers and
their partner companies.
So how would you how would we
configure the system to get
partner companies for,
inter customers
or companies we
already have. So we configured
the system in this
manner. Right?
We needed a few
loaders, sales,
company, product.
We needed the corresponding
transformer for each one of
those loaders so
we can transform
this information into
graph formations.
And the key
configuration here,
the key implementation,
it was the partner
extractor. Right?
The partner extractor was
implemented by crawling,
partner page in
the company website,
analyzing the logos
through deep
learning models,
and connecting
the company with
their partner company's URLs.
To in order to keep
this up to date,
we also, put in
partner refresh.
And after configuring
the system
this way and letting
it work for a few,
a few days,
we got this nice
graph as we can
infer knowledge directly from
simply by granting
it and getting
this nice, UI.
And what we see
here is that we
have company URL cell and some
other companies.
And here we can
see an image of
two companies that buy things
from Intel and their
partner companies.
So if we look at specifically
the graph formation
we chose to
use and since this
is, let's say,
quite different than
you would expect,
basically, in order to keep
things dynamic,
everything that has more than
a single relationship
is a node.
As you cannot connect a single
edge between more
than two nodes.
Right? URL can be
used by several
companies, so we
deemed it a note.
Sale is an action
of purchase,
you can say.
Company a purchased
this product,
but it's also
a sales transaction
that may have different
relationships such
as buyer, seller,
product, etcetera.
So we made it a node as well.
So we were pro nodes,
as it makes things
more easy to manage,
easy to persist,
and you would not lose
any information.
But while but while it's great
for inferring
simple or inferring
knowledge directly
from the graph
by simple queries,
it is not optimal for training
machine learning models as we
will soon see.
Another principle,
we found important,
was to keep trace,
as I mentioned,
of information and
where it comes from,
as well as the option
that there
could be inconsistencies when
retrieving data from external
data sources. And
this was the key
feature, like, enriching with
external information.
And I'll illustrate.
We remember company a.
So maybe we went
on out to some
company a's Wiki
page and we've
classified that
this Wiki page,
let's say, predicted
that company
a belongs to
the cloud industry
with some sort
of probability.
So we can do this,
but then we lost a lot of
information along the way.
Like, we lost that
company a belongs
to the cloud industry through
this Wiki page, which also,
talks about NAR and,
also what if company
a has another
Wiki page. So we don't want to
keep track of all
these things,
and then maybe
company a belongs
to the software
industry through
some Wiki page and the cloud
another Wiki page.
And maybe later on,
we would like to
run an algorithm
on top of all our Wiki pages
class reclassifying
them since we got,
like, a better algorithm.
And we do not have to,
touch or change anything with
company a since
everything goes
through those Wiki pages.
So that just gives us more
flexibility and we don't lose
any information,
which is basically
we want a good
knowledge base. So
we kept everything.
Having said that,
what I said about
machine learning,
this may require
to query a fab
graph for training machine
learning and
artificial intelligence
models. As knowledge graph
algorithms usually
aim to capture
some sort of
correlation between
nodes and edges.
It link prediction,
entity resolution,
for instance, deduplication,
classification, by using other
nodes or maybe even link based
clustering. All of these,
can be done usually
by predicting
the existence of
a a triplet via
some sort of score function.
So when you wanna train your
algorithm on top of
a knowledge graph,
this simply won't
work as there
are these Wiki page
intermediate nodes.
And they disturb the algorithm
because it doesn't need it in
order to predict
the edge between
company a and
the cloud industry.
So this would be
a better choice
for the algorithm or the only
choice that the algorithm can
run on top of.
But fortunately,
this transition
between the full
blown knowledge
graph into a sub graph
for the algorithm
is usually very
fast complexity
as well as code wise,
at least according to our data
scientists as this
is what they do.
They query for a subgraph and
train the model on top of it.
I just wanted to
see where I stand,
time wise.
So the last piece I wanna,
touch upon is when
you have a really
reliable, knowledge graph,
we can create new knowledge
using the graph
we already have
and enriching it without going
to outside sources
using knowledge
graph algorithms.
And this is a paper we've,
published about
a year ago showing
how we used our
knowledge graph
in order to perform customer
segmentation into verticals,
and the specific deep learning
and machine learning
models used
in this study,
relay on Wikipedia information
as well as home page
information and,
of course,
internal information
we already knew about
those companies.
And all of the above,
could be found in our
knowledge graph,
our knowledge base,
is thus and and thus enabled
this research. And if you find
this idea intriguing,
you can give it a look at,
Google Scholar or
the Intel AI website.
So this was, like,
an overview of what,
we were trying to solve in our
sales AI platform and how we
grow a knowledge graph.
A little bit glimpse
of the architecture
and the capabilities we found
were crucial in order to make
this happen. And
I've I hope you
found this interesting.
And, I believe I'm I'm done,
and I'm open to questions.
We do have a couple
of questions
for you, actually. Okay.
So some people some
people were asking,
like, if how did you manage to
use Neo four j, with
triples and the,
semantics part and
all of that stuff.
But, actually, they already
answered among themselves that
there is a plug in that,
for that from Neo four j that
allows you to do that.
So I'm going to Okay.
Give you a more
specific question,
which is, what is the schema
that you keep inside Kafka?
And if you serialize
your graph data,
JSON or something similar.
So, what was the schema that
what's the schema that you use
inside Kafka?
What do you mean?
This is the question.
It's, no.
So I I I'll I'll be
happy to answer it,
but I I don't really I don't
really understand
the question.
So, basically, whoever asked
the question, it's
probably a good
question. So you
can ask me, like,
in Slack. Maybe we can talk,
and you can explain
the question,
and then I'll
answer it. Maybe.
Okay. So let's
see what else we
got there for you. Right.
We have a question from who's
asking how would analysts or
business users,
gather insights,
from your knowledge graph,
or is it only for use by data
scientists? Oh,
so, for leads,
like, the beginning
of the process
finding, simple insights,
like the partner
company insights
we saw.
They can system analysts can,
take this query
the graph looking
for some manually looking for
some insights before we start
automating them,
showing those snapshots
to the business
units to see if
they're viable.
And if they are, we
can start building,
more robust models
and solutions
that will they won't
need the graph
image anymore like
the the drawing.
They will simply get
the recommendation,
according to the graph.
But this is mainly
the querying
is done for,
for the first
stages when you're
looking for hints of things
which you can, get,
benefits from
opportunities from.
Okay. There's another
question from,
Matthias Sisbuie,
if I'm pronouncing correctly,
who's asking whether you can
speak about
the iterative process
to build, such to build this
from scratch.
So, actually,
it's not it's as
as you've seen,
it it's composed of, like,
five different microservices
with a message bus.
So this is more of a software
engineering question
because we first,
we put everything
into place, like,
all these capabilities,
and they were empty. Right?
They did, like,
simple things or
they almost did
nothing. And then we started
once everything was ticking,
we started putting
in the logic
inside the system.
And, so but that's
an iterative,
microservice framework,
development process we use,
most of the times.
We put, the entire
framework, like,
the key things in
the framework.
We mock it, and
then we started
putting the logic
inside. Okay.
I have another question from
Deborah who's asking if you
could further
expand on how you
handle entity resolution,
meaning how the loaders and
transformers know that two
websites are referring
to company a,
but they're, for instance,
spelled differently.
I'm not sure I I understand,
but I'll try. Like,
the way we transform this
information into
graph formations,
Currently, we did
an expert that
would manually define
using this YAML,
DSL we created which piece of
information turns into what.
But it does so one
time as usually
we work with,
APIs which return
data in a known
structure. Right?
Like, you get the JSON,
you know what
fields to expect.
So we do that for
each entity.
But we do it one
time and we let
it run on all of
the same type entities,
if that was the question.
I'm not sure.
But even if it wasn't,
I think I think the question
probably refers to entity
disambiguation. Say,
which is a very well known and
very thorny issue
in Novice Graph.
So how do you Oh, okay. Okay.
So when you get the external
information and you wanna make
sure it belongs indeed
to the company,
like the example
with the Wiki page.
So we ran,
when we fetch external
information,
we always have a matching
algorithm that
matches the internal
entity that we already know is
correct by company a with some
external information
we got from
this Wiki page
that claims it's
company a.
And we do this cross matching
algorithm and we
give it, a score.
Like the. What I
I I think it's
confidence level that I wrote
here and we give it a score,
how much we believe
that company
a actually, like,
this Wiki page
actually belongs
to company a. We do not make
this a strict connection.
It's kind of
a loose connection
with some certainty level.
So if you know,
it's query the graph and say,
I want only weekly information
about company a, which,
is above ninety
percent, certainty,
like, confidence,
if it makes sense.
Okay. There's a quick one,
and I'm guessing the answer is
probably no, but I'm going to
ask you anyway if
you have, like,
a gift card for this.
Fortunately, no.
I'm saying
fortunately because,
the the process of getting,
extremely difficult.
I would love to do so.
I cannot do it on
my own. So no.
I I I don't, but
I I'll be I'll
be glad to
contribute any piece
of knowledge that I have to
anyone that wanna talk.
I'll I'll do it for
free and for fun.
That's that's fair enough.
You know, an open
invitation to
people as well. Yeah.
I have a there's another one
from Mark who's
asking something
quite fundamental, actually.
Why are you using
your message bus?
Couldn't you work directly on
the graph database?
Well, that's, again,
a software engineering one.
Since you wanna
you wanna control
one of the basic things with
asynchronous system that you
wanna control the throughput.
You would don't want
burst to turn down,
like, destroy your system.
That's why we have Kafka.
You have back
what's called back
pressure. If you got a lot of
information flowing in and you
don't have enough connections
to the database
and the throughput
of the database is not enough
because there's an IO limit,
the bottleneck
will probably be
your graph build. Right?
And you want things, like,
to queue up behind
your graph builder.
You don't want the the service
itself trying to
create a graph
because a lot of services will
try to create a graph and they
just bring it down.
You wanna control
the throughput,
and that's one of the reasons
you use the message bus and
the one of the reasons Lambda
functions use, SQS, etcetera.
Okay. Makes sense.
I think we're good, actually.
I mean, we can as you said,
you're on Slack as well,
so you can continue
the conversation
there if people have even more
specific questions because I
think some of them
were actually
quite specific already.
So I guess we're
good to wrap up.
Thank you once again, Aran,
and we'll see you.
Thank you. Thank you.
Bye bye. Cheers. Bye.